today on the matt wall show over the
last year i have been on a secret
journey spanning the globe pursuing an
answer to the ultimate question the
question that defines a generation today
i'm finally ready to begin to reveal
what i uncovered we'll talk about that
also the supreme court hearings for
contagion brown jackson continued
yesterday with democrats and jackson
herself lashing out indignant
indignantly that anyone would dare
question her stellar judicial record of
going easy on child sex predators plus
home depot goes woke democrats pushed to
extend these student loan payment freeze
though they can't really explain why and
even though men and women are exactly
equal and no different at all the army
has still lowered its fitness standards
again
to include more women we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt
wells show
[Applause]
[Music]
with the ever increasing numbers of car
makes and models it's now impossible to
stock all the parts you need in a
traditional chain storefront so why
endure often pointless or seemingly
intimidating questioning about the
specifications of your vehicle only to
have the counterman
order the parts on his computer anyway i
know one thing about me is i'm so
intimidated at auto parts stores and
also i call them countermen
you have computers with access to
rockauto.com at home and in your pocket
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil and even new
carpet whether it's your classic or your
daily driver get everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door the rockauto.com catalog is
easy
very uh unique and and you can navigate
it with these quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brand specifications and prices you
prefer
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers so
all you got to do is go to rockauto.com
see all the parts available for your car
truck and write walsh in there how did
you hear about us box so they know that
i sent you
i think it was about four years ago when
i first posed the question what is a
woman i had started focusing on the
scourge of gender ideology years before
that and argued against it in a million
different ways
making a million different arguments in
a million words or more and somehow over
those several years it never occurred to
me to ask the most basic question of all
i had heard the phrase trans women are
women
so many times and yet for so long i
never thought to respond what does that
mean what do you think a woman is what
are you trying to say
four years ago for whatever reason it
finally dawned on me i realized i didn't
need a million words only for what is a
woman
now once i realized that this is the
question really the only question we
need to ask the question that pulls down
the whole edifice of gender ideology
i started asking it and asking it more
asking it over and over again
i asked it for years on social media in
speeches and interviews
it was clear that the proponents of
gender ideology the architects of the
current madness which is gripping our
society we're not going to answer the
question because they can't
and they had elected instead to simply
ignore me which was easy enough
so i reached a point where i realized
that either
i could keep shouting into the abyss
uh it's definitely an option i do it all
the time or simply give it up and move
on with my life that i can't do i can't
really give anything up or i could take
drastic action
and i chose the latter option
if they wouldn't answer my question i
decided that i would force their hand
and so i hatched an elaborate scheme
that
over the past year has taken me across
the globe and got me into the room with
some of the leading quote-unquote
experts in the field i talked to
politicians academics pediatricians
psychiatrists
trans activists surgeons and many many
more i went everywhere from
san francisco to the african wilderness
and yes i did all of this essentially
because nobody on the left would respond
to my tweet
an overreaction perhaps
but i don't believe in proportional
responses as you've probably noticed by
now i've had to keep this project secret
for a year finally we we can announce it
though we announced it today and there's
still so much that i can't say and that
will will be revealed in the near future
we'll have a full trailer for it in the
coming weeks but for now here's a very
quick
sneak peek watch
i have traveled all over the world
for the past year
asking one simple question
what is
a woman
what is a woman what is it what is it i
don't know
people are laughing is that is that a
dumb question
i've been asking everybody this and
almost nobody can answer it what is a
woman what is a woman
that's a great question
[Music]
if one person could tell me what a woman
is
congressman thank you for for being here
i think this interview is over let's
turn off the cameras i just wanted to
know what is a woman and you're not
gonna find out
it's not a complicated question
now that um
that congressman
very much regretted
inviting me to uh his office for a
sit-down he was
you know not the only interview subject
to regret their life decisions i can
tell you that but i can't tell you much
more than that um when it comes to
specific specifics but but i can tell
you
that all i did
was ask the most basic questions um if
gender ideology was going to collapse on
camera
and it did in spectacular fashion
i wanted it to collapse under the weight
of its own incoherence i wanted the
allegedly smart highly credentialed
advocates of this stuff to just bury
themselves and they did too one line in
scripture that i returned to in my head
over and over again as we filmed this
project is romans 1 22 professing
themselves to be wise they became fools
i watched the wise make fools of
themselves over and over again in fact
much of the real wisdom that i did
encounter and i encountered some you'll
see that in the film also
came from simple normal people the kinds
of people that the wise would say are
fools
so we asked the question how did the
left
get away with propagating these ideas
for so long
while somehow never having to answer
even the most basic questions about it
how did they conquer western society
with an ideology that falls over and
shatters into a thousand pieces with a
simple flick of a finger
it's this enormous seemingly imposing
totally ubiquitous thing something that
has
reshaped our civilization changed the
way people see themselves and their own
species
and yet all you have to do is walk up
and just poke it just just poke it and
it pops like an overinflated balloon
how could something so flimsy
so thin
have so much success
the answer is for one thing people are
scared it has threatened the sane into
silence that was that was something that
became abundantly clear as soon as i set
out on my what is a woman journey
because everywhere we went um almost
everybody that we talked to even the
ones who who knew the truth and were
willing to say it
even then most of them still look kind
of from side to side and whispered like
they were spies passing state secrets
there's a lot of fear out there because
the left is always standing in the
middle of the crowd with a bomb strapped
to its chest
threatening to hit the red button if
anybody dares question them
but what you find so often is that it's
a dummy bomb
strapped to a dummy
people are afraid of a phantom now
it's true that the left owns all the
institutions and so they do have the
power to punish you i myself have
already basically accepted that at least
some of my social media platforms
will not survive the release of this
film i'm already expecting that this
movie is somewhat of a kamikaze mission
in that way
which is why i wanted to get it right
because it might be my my last act who
knows at least on
when it comes to my access to the
internet um
i know there will probably be some steep
consequences especially considering
the people who we embarrass in this film
and how badly we embarrass them
so the fear people have is not entirely
imaginary
and yet the fear has scared people to
such an extent
that they think they can't even talk
about this at all they treat the subject
the subject of what a woman is what
biological sex is like it's like it's
literally radioactive
the fear causes people to fall silent
and the silence only emboldens the
ideological terrorists even more
the second factor is that the left is
very good
and making simple things seem
complicated
not just on this issue but all issues
what they do is they try to drown you in
jargon and buzzwords and caveats and
exceptions to the rule and any other
ball they need to throw at you to
distract you from the topic at hand
soon before you know it you're off the
path you're knee-deep in the weeds can't
remember where you were going or why or
what you were talking about
and then
when you're out there
in the muck
off the trail confused
they'll come along and say you see this
is all so complicated you should stop
thinking about this subject just leave
it to us
rest your puny little brain child and
let us think for you
trust the experts
what they don't expect is that you'll
take them up on it and actually go talk
to those experts
and ask them the questions
they're supposed to be able to so easily
answer
actually ask the questions
you know what by that i mean don't just
sit there and let them talk at you
but ask the questions
apply some skepticism to what they're
telling you just a little bit
that's not what they're expecting
that's exactly what i did
and the results are
tremendous as you'll see soon enough
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
uh you'll also enjoy i mean i don't know
this this this is what's going to be
hard before we release the full trailer
that this i'm going to want to talk
about so much of the stuff in this movie
and i can't
um
but uh i don't cause i don't want to
steal our own thunder here when the
trailer comes out but
you did see one clip there in the in the
um in the teaser in a sneak peek of uh
you know me at the women's march with
the sandwich board sign that said what
is a woman and so i will tell you that
um
if you go to the women's march where
people are marching
for women
and you ask them what is that exactly um
they they do not respond kindly to the
question so if you want to know how to
get kicked out of a women's march
that's how you do it
i admit i also had a bullhorn you know
so i was
i didn't take the most subtle approach
in that particular
instance but anyway you'll see
you'll see all that it's all it's all
really good really excited about it okay
um
so let's go
to here we'll we'll go back to the
supreme court
nomination hearings there's a lot of
different clips and stuff i want to play
we're just going to kind of go through
these maybe somewhat at random um we've
been hearing about of course
the two things that come out of the
supreme court hearing uh one
very topical for our for our purposes is
that catanji brown jackson wants to be
supreme court justice and yet cannot
tell you what a woman is and in fact on
that subject uh ted cruz yesterday
returned to it
and uh
and asked her some questions making the
point that
there are some real consequences
obviously
to having a justice who doesn't know
what a woman is
the most basic consequence is that she
doesn't have apparently or at least just
pretending not to have any kind of grasp
on reality and you would think that
that's something you would want from
your justice but also
it presents some real legal problems if
you don't know how to define this word
and so ted cruz got into that with her
and we'll see how that went
you told her that that you couldn't
define
what a woman is
uh that you are not a biologist which
which i think you're the the only
supreme court nominee in history who's
been unable to answer
the question what is a woman
let me ask you as a
judge
how would you determine if a plaintiff
had
article 3 standing
to challenge a gender-based rule
regulation policy
without being able to determine what a
woman was
so senator i know that i'm a woman i
know that
senator blackburn is a woman and the
woman who i
admire most in the world is in the room
today my mother
um it sounded as though well but the
question but let me ask under the modern
leftist sensibilities if if
i decide right now that that i'm a woman
um
then
apparently i'm a woman does that mean
that i would have article 3 standing to
challenge a gender-based restriction
senator to the extent that you are
asking me about
who has the ability to bring lawsuits
based on gender those kinds of issues
are working their way through the courts
and i'm not able to comment on them
now ted cruz had one line of questioning
he was trying to go down and trying to
get an answer out of her and i
appreciate that i do wish that he had
um
interjected with a follow-up when she
said
i know i'm a woman
obvious follow-up is how do you know
that
and that is also a question that comes
up in in the film that i discovered
that's like
there's the evasions okay well are you a
woman yes how do you know that
um and then you see the meltdown happen
even more i just i wish he'd asked that
question because there's no how do you
know you're a woman and you know you you
have to give
a biologically based answer
or or you can say
i just feel like one okay so anyone who
feels like one is one
and what do you mean you feel like one
like what is a woman feeling and
how can you differentiate that between i
mean if you're a woman already
then whatever feelings you're having are
the feelings that a woman's having so
how can the feelings determine
um
so we didn't go down that but but it
does create of course all kinds of
problems especially with the way our
legal system is set up right now
and all of these gender-based laws and
everything
if you want to have those kinds of laws
then
how can you do that if you erase the
distinction between men and women
it's just like if you were to declare
that
race
does not exist
and that anyone can decide or rather
that it's totally fluid and subjective
and anyone can decide to be whatever
race they want to be well one of the
consequences of that is that now all the
hate crime laws that you also support
and have created um
how do those work out how do you how do
you determine that
so
she ducks and dodges there not even very
well but she ducks and dodges tries to
evade it
um
and she does the same when it comes to
the questioning on
her sentencing of child sex predators
and especially people who have used or
consumed or distributed child porn now
the media and the democrats continue to
be very scandalized that this is coming
up at all we'll see some of that in a
moment cory booker was just shocked and
offended he was totally floored by what
was happening this is unheard of
for a supreme court justice to be
treated this way
and again like we said yesterday it from
the democrats perspective it is sort of
unheard of
and shocking to them
because these questions are all about
her actual judicial record
and her legal philosophy her personal
philosophies her worldview
you know things relevant to the job
that's what the democrats find shocking
because they're not used to that all
they care about is usually digging into
somebody's personal life looking at
their high school yearbook how much
beard
did they drink in college and so on
um
the question obviously about
sentencing for child pornography
is
incredibly relevant
because
um
this goes down
to just a real fundamental level
her concept of justice
you know she's a judge
she wants to literally take on she wants
to be someone who we call justice
justice jackson
which does actually sound kind of cool i
gotta admit um it sounds cool anyway
that would be the only good thing is
just how it sounds just the name uh
everything else would be would would not
be good having her in the supreme court
because although she would have this
name of justice
she doesn't have any concept of just
like she has no concept of what a woman
is even though she's a woman
you know when you think about justice
what what is justice to you i think we
should know that if you want to be a
justice on the supreme court
her concept of justice apparently is to
on every occasion when she had the
opportunity to give a lighter sentence
to child porn offenders than the federal
guidelines allow on every single
occasion
now she was asked whether she regrets
any of these decisions
you know federal guidelines calls call
for years and she decides to give
somebody a few months does she regret
that and here is her answer to that
what
i regret
is that in a hearing
about
my qualifications to
be
a justice on the supreme court we've
spent a lot of time
focusing
on this
small subset of my sentences and i've
tried to explain you regret that we're
focusing on your cases i don't
understand no no i'm i'm i'm talking
about the fact that you're talking about
child pronounced
very serious cases i'm glad we agree on
that
i regret that you're talking about my
judicial record that's what she regrets
yeah it may have been a minority of the
cases that she dealt with but they're
very important cases
and the reason why you harp on them is
because unlike some of the other cases
that she may have dealt with this speaks
again
to her fundamental concept of justice
and based on her record i'm not sure she
has any concept of it at all
or if she does her idea of justice is to
if you have someone who's already
victimized children sexually victimized
children
and by consuming child porn by
obtaining child pornography you have
participated in
the abuse of children
obviously i would think it was obvious
so her idea of justice is uh someone
someone
is convicted of that
you know
slap on the wrist basically a few months
in jail maybe and throw them back out
into society
give them another shot give them another
try
and i doubt very much that there have
been uh very many cases
of somebody convicted of child
pornography they spent a couple months
in jail
and then go back out into society and
that's the last time
they ever go near any of that stuff
that's just not the way it works
there's a trajectory with these kinds of
things
when somebody has that in their soul
and they're falling down
this
pit
um
it it doesn't just stop
in the middle uh you know kind of
mid-air and they
end up flying back in the other
direction towards the light
not going to say it's impossible nothing
is impossible with god but it's it is
not common and it's not likely
usually somebody starts with child
pornography
and then
it doesn't take very long
soon they're physically victimizing
children in real life
although even the child pornography i
mean those are children who are being
physically victimized in real life and
that the person who is obtaining it is
participating again in that abuse
so this all this all is relevant but she
says that it's not um but it's also not
just child pornography i want to go back
a day before this this is a clip we
didn't play yesterday but um
she also has a habit of light sentences
not just for child pornographers and
people who have obtained child
pornography but also drug kingpins as
well let's listen to that question
judge jackson before you granted this
fentanyl kingpin's motion to reduce his
sentence did you contact any of the
victims from his case
senator thank you for allowing me to
address mr young's situation i i asked a
simple question did you contact the
victims in his case or not
senator mr young was not released his
sentence was reduced and i did not
contact the victims in that case because
there were no victims he committed
a crime a drug crime there were no
identifiable victims in his case
drug crime is not a victimless crime a
hundred thousand americans were killed
by overdoses understood
there were no victims of a
fentanyl
drug kingpin
how many people does fentanyl kill
every year thousands
a victimless crime
that's an especially peculiar view from
someone on the left although that is
basically people on the left think but
it doesn't really make any sense because
these are also people who uh don't
believe in free will at all and so
given that you don't really believe in
free will you of all people
should agree that um you know
a drug lord
someone who's selling drugs that's not a
victimless crime there are victims of
that
um but then going back to yesterday
cory booker after listening to all of
this and all of these republicans who
would dare
dare ask her questions about the kinds
of sentences she's passed down and what
her judicial record is
her judicial philosophy
he's listened to all of this and he's
totally outraged and so we'll play we've
got a couple of clips here we'll we'll
play as much of them as we can
um
let's uh let's start with clip four
i got letters from
leaders
of victims rights groups
survivors
of assault
all
saying sort of the same thing with the
national review feel proud about
yourself you brought together right and
left in this
in this in this
calling out
of people that will sit up here
and try to pull out from cases
and try to put themselves in a position
where they're the defenders of our
children
to a person who has children
to a person whose family
goes out in streets and defends children
i i mean this is a new new low and
what's especially surprising about this
is we didn't have shut up cory we
stopped that there
he's getting geared up you know he's
about to we've seen this before he
especially likes it during the during
supreme court hearings i mean famously
this is a guy that declared that he was
spartacus so he's he's getting geared up
for another spartacus moment uh this guy
is he's a performer he loves the
theatrics the this is a classic theater
kid
you know situation here um he's not a
very good performer like so many theater
kids in high school but he he loves it
and so he's getting into the into the
motions he's about to really he's got
he's got a full monologue he's got
prepared we're going to get to that here
in a second
um
but he points out that well how could
they make these claims
about uh someone who's a mother
well yeah that's actually a good point
you know if you're a mother and you have
kids
even if you don't have kids
i'm not sure i understand how you could
go so lenient on
a crime as heinous as child pornography
you don't need to have kids to see why
hor
why that is so horrible
um
but considering that you do have kids
that's all the more reason why you would
think you would sympathize 100 with the
victims or children and not at all with
the
the criminal
who's a violent
sexually abusive scumbag
uh so he's he's he's shocked by this he
can't believe that's happening and then
we get to
this is when he's going for the oscar
here this is what he wants on his oscar
reel uh and let's watch
that is the story of how you got to this
desk
you and i and everyone here generations
of folk who came here
and said america i'm irish you may say
no irish or dogs need to apply but i'm
going to show this country that i can be
free here i can make this country love
me as much as i love
it chinese americans first forced into
near
slave labor building our railroads
connecting our country
saw the ugliest of america but they were
gonna build their home here and say
america you may not love me yet but i'm
gonna make this nation live up to its
promise and hope
lgbtq americans
from stonewall women to seneca
hidden figures who didn't even get their
play until somebody
i feel so bad for the woman in the
background there how's she keeping a
straight face through all this look at
this guy's face can we just put look at
his what a lunatic
at least he's playing one on tv
and well he had to throw in so we've got
to um he starts with irish americans and
then we go we get to to lgbtq of course
and now he's really getting ramped up he
throws in hidden figures he's just
thrown everything into it
uh let's keep playing it this is fun
about them and how they were critical
for us defying gravity all of these
people loved america
and so you faced insults here that were
shocking to me well actually not
shocking
but you are here because of that kind of
love
and nobody's taking this away from me
isn't that nice so you got five more
folk to go through
five more of us
and then you can sit back and let us
have all the debates and i'm gonna tell
you it's gonna be a well-charted senate
floor because it's not gonna stop
they're gonna accuse you of this and
that heck in honor of your
person who shares your birthday you
might be called a communist
well yeah but don't worry
reason to suspect
don't worry
oh here we go
god has got you
and how do i know that
because you're here
and i know what it's taken
for you to sit in that seat
uh yeah cory booker pretending to be
religious is about as believable as what
he was pretending to date rosario dawson
whoever it was
um and we've got and then jackson is
crying there she's getting emotional
remember when
uh
kavanaugh got emotional during his
supreme court hearing
there might have been some tears welling
up in the eyes and
and he got angry
and a little indignant himself
and and you can recall all of the
mockery
coming his direction from people on the
left
cory booker was there he didn't come to
his defense
he wasn't he didn't find that shocking
he was participating in it
um so we yeah we we made fun of
kavanaugh for getting emotional
meanwhile he's sitting there
um on the biggest stage in front of in
front of the world being accused of uh
of being a serial gang rapist
and for that
he wasn't supposed to get emotional it
was you know it showed that he didn't
what was it he didn't have the right
temperament
to be on the supreme court
because if you get a little bit upset
and perturbed after sitting there for
three days and being told over and over
again that you're a serial gang rapist
um then you don't have the right
temperament
well what does that say about about
jackson that she's uh getting emotional
and crying she got a little bit angry
and all they're doing is asking about
her judicial record that's it
uh great performance though from cory
booker very good performance i mean by
by political standards i mean it's you
know um
it's about as good as you get when it
comes to the theater there's one other
clip i want to play for you so
the media
of course as well coming to
jackson's defense
on the um
especially on the child porn part of
this and now in fairness to the media
there's really no non-creepy way of
defending
lenient sentences for child porn
distributors and people who use child
porn
so there's no non-creepy way to do it
but the media is choosing the creepiest
possible way so let's play this clip
from nbc
they spent a lot of time on this
specific issue of an 18 year old from
washington who the sentencing guidelines
would have called for an eight-year
sentence the prosecutors recommended a
two-year sentence and judge jackson
imposed a sentence of three months and
so there was some discussion about why
she did that
i've looked at the records in this case
and i think
apparently judge jackson just doesn't
recall this case and that that's
understandable she had many many
sentencing in something like 500 court
decisions but the specifics in this case
suggest that
this was a
an 18 year old who was curious about
this kind of sexual activity that he
sought out
the court records show that a detective
when he realized that this young man was
uploading some of this contacted him and
said how would you like to have real
sexual activity with uh my 12 year old
daughter which was make believe and this
young man never responded to him and
there was a psychiatrist who evaluated
the young man and said this was
basically his sort of curiosity about a
specific kind of sexual activity he
wasn't interested in younger people he
was just sort of curious about this for
his own purposes that he was not a
pedophile so those were the kinds of
things apparently that judge jackson
took into account in that specific case
that senator hawley spent a lot of time
on
that's uh pete williams with nbc i think
we should put his
msnbc which put his name with that said
pete williams just saying i was curious
it's not a pedophile
it's just uh curious about child
pornography
these people are are just degenerates
all of them
okay let's move on to a couple other
topics
so here's some material from a home
depot in canada
talking about privilege this was uh
posted
by libs of tick tock
always doing the work
you know this is like what really just
it tells you the state of uh of the
media that
i would say that probably the top
journalist
in the country right now is the
anonymous person who runs a libs of tick
tock account on twitter
this is actual journalism finding real
stories about things that are happening
and and telling people about it um so
here's here's something it says home
depot has gone woke and there's this
worksheet that was handed out at a home
depot in canada
and it says leading practices
unpacking privilege
privilege now and a special benefit or
advantage that may be earned or unearned
and then it goes into there's two kinds
of privilege social privilege
um that's a special unearned advantage
or entitlement used to one's own benefit
or to the detriment of others these
groups can be advantaged based on social
class age disability ethnic or racial
category gender gender identity sexual
orientation and religion
uh and that's certainly that that
definitely exists there's no question
about it i mean there are people who
have because of their demographic
category they have social privileges
there are people who have social
privileges based on their
quote-unquote gender identity
um
in fact the kinds of people who use
phrases like gender identity and think
that that's a real thing those are the
ones with social privilege
if you're in the if you're if you can
claim membership
to the lgbt club somehow
fit your way under that ever-expanding
umbrella then you have social privilege
but that's not the kind of privilege i
talk about i assume
um and then also white privilege that's
societal privilege that benefits white
people beyond what is commonly
experienced by people of color under the
same social political and economic
circumstances and then it goes into this
so those are the two broad categories
and then there's sort of these
subcategories and it says what privilege
looks like
if you're confident that the police
exist to protect you
you have white privilege
that's what white privilege so if you
if you do not believe
that you're being hunted down by cops
who want to execute you
while you're just walking down the
street then you have privilege
i would think of that okay if that's
privilege that's just the privilege of
not being paranoid
if while growing up college was an
expectation of you not a dream
you have class privilege
if you can expect time off from work to
celebrate your religious holidays
you have christian
privilege if you can use public
bathrooms without stares fear or anxiety
you have cisgender privilege
so that's that's nobody by the way like
who
does anyone feel 100 comfortable in
public restrooms
it would be kind of strange if you did
like there's always a little bit of
anxiety in public restrooms
um
and then also able-bodied privilege and
heterosexual privilege
and can i also say
just a note that on the christian
privilege thing i've always seen it as
the other way around like
if you're getting off of work and you
get off time off of school
for someone else's religious holidays
how does that mean that you have the
privilege it seems like you get the
extra privilege there it's not even your
holiday and you get to take off
so what's what's the privilege exactly
if we're if we're inviting you we
celebrate christmas and we're saying
well you know what we're gonna give
everybody off
you're not even christian we're gonna
give you a christmas gift and you get to
take off also
that what is that you being oppressed
you're being attacked
um
no the the privilege would be
uh we're gonna take off for christmas
but but all of you still have to work
um
able-bodied and heterosexual privilege
so this is a home depot this is what
they're doing at home depot now home
depot responded the ap reached out to
them here's the ap says home depot said
wednesday that a worksheet about
privilege that went viral is an
unauthorized document from the company's
canada division an anonymous twitter
account with the handle libs of tick
tock uh
posted it we know that
and
they said that um
home depot issued a statement saying
that while it supports diversity at the
company the worksheet was not created or
approved by its corporate diversity
equity and inclusion department
companies said this this was a resource
in our canada division and not part of
any required programming
so that's this has already been labeled
online as misinformation and debunked
and everything and it's not this was
this was something that was used at a
home depot
and that was handed out to employees
apparently at a home depot it just
didn't come down from the top
i mean eventually it will though because
they they admit that they have
well you know we have a corporate
diversity equity and inclusion
department it's just like that's
that particular bit of brainwashing
isn't something that came from us
so we have each individual home depot
can do their own brainwashing we have
our but we have the corporate version
and that's not part of it yet
but that's all
that's all inevitable once that the
whole point of having a diversity equity
and inclusion department is precisely
for things like this
and it's kind of significant too there's
a certain significance to home depot
starting to go woke because
um as far as i know up until now they
were one of the few companies that
had basically stayed neutral
um
they were one of the few companies that
up until this point
you know at least hadn't gone out of the
way to display their wokeness
and that apparently is uh that that was
that was never going to last i suppose
okay finally from the daily wires a
group of congressional democrats is
pushing for president joe biden to
continue the payment freeze on federal
student loans at least through the end
of 2022 in a letter to biden on monday a
group of 43 house democrats led by
pennsylvania representative conor lamb
said the biden
administration needed to continue the
progress made by democrats in the wake
of the kova 19 pandemic by extending the
pause or else the rapid transition to
repayment
would risk borrowers being delinquent
of defaulting on their loans
so we know the tactic now they want to
get rid of student loans they don't have
student loan forgiveness
which just means that of course that
somebody else will be forced to pay for
them uh you can't actually just snap
your fingers and make the loans go away
but i think that they've found what they
what they believe to be a way around it
so instead of having student loan
forgiveness we'll just have a
pause on student loans and then we'll
just keep on extending it
no reason can really be given for this
and everybody else with all their other
debts uh they still have to pay back
those debts but we're going to make an
exception for student loans of course
they can't explain it but
they can't explain anything else of
course as we've seen like what is a
woman
we'll get now to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
the chrome to your dome says
as a psychology as a psychology phd
student
i really wish i could uh i've chosen a
different profession my school and the
apa are woke beyond belief
yeah i i hear this
from people you know inside the
psychiatric industry all the time and i
don't even need to hear because it's
quite obvious to me
there's not much of a secret
um
that the psychiatric industry is
far far far left and has been for a long
time
and that that's a problem that we need
to start talking about in a serious way
on the right at least
um
we talk about the bias in the news media
we talk about indoctrination by
hollywood we talk about it in the school
system and it matters in all those
places obviously it matters a lot
especially in the school system
but at a certain point we got to talk
about
therapists psychiatrists
because most of these people are
dyed in the wool full-blown
ideologues leftists
and they're dealing with very vulnerable
people
who tend to trust them implicitly
now
schools are in the same position they're
dealing with vulnerable people who are
children children tend to trust the
teachers and so they take advantage of
that
by indoctrinating
uh same exact thing is happening all
over the place with psychiatrists and
therapists
the more that we can
talk about that the better
let's see
john says i've been a loyal subscriber
of matt for a couple years now i think
his points are really well articulated
and he's helped me realize how bad the
delusion in today's society has gotten
however today i found out he pronounces
the word crayon
how he pronounces the word cran and i'm
not sure i can
look at him the same anymore well this
is
well because what do you want me to say
crayon
crayon
this is anti-marylander bigotry i get
made fun of all the time for the way i
pronounce certain words
some of the pronunciation is just the
fact that i'm stupid
a lot of it is the fact that i'm from
maryland and in maryland if you've ever
been there
the accent doesn't really make sense it
tends to pop up it's sort of
schizophrenic it pops up in these
there isn't uh
a real pattern to it all the time that
you can always notice but but the one
thing is we just pronounce we have a
strange way of pronouncing basic words
and um at least that's my excuse anyway
uh
and
finally vakula says thank you matt for
your kind words of encouragement to
those in despair i suffer from
depression and i contest to the truth of
your words go outside play with a pet
talk to another human being it all helps
immensely even when the pills fail
yeah well that's
i appreciate you saying that because um
yeah you would think
that just pointing out that hey get some
exercise get some sun
think about what you're eating what
you're putting into your body think
about your diet
you'd think that all this would be seen
as just sort of helpful encouragement
some some good good advice basic advice
you don't have to be a genius to know
this
but people tend to get really upset when
it comes to any
mental issue if you go outside of of
just saying okay go to a psychiatrist uh
get some pills take the pills if you go
anywhere outside of that then you're
accused of being you know cruel somehow
when of course exactly the opposite is
the case well as you heard right at the
top of the show telling you again i've
been working on a top secret project for
over a year it is called what is a woman
and uh i believe
this could be the most important
question and film of 2022. i i actually
do believe that i think that this is uh
the most important
film that you'll see at least this year
we fearlessly and unflinchingly question
the logic of a trans movement that has
taken aim at women and children and
we're going after that it's it's it's
not just around the fringes here that
we're dealing with this issue we are
going right at the concept itself that's
what we're doing
this fight is for everything it's for
the truth itself what is a woman coming
2022 go to what is a woman.com um and
also
as the beloved author of the
best-selling children's lgbtq plus book
johnny the walrus i am now a very
important voice in the transgender
conversation and i can add you know i'm
a documentarian now that i can add to
children's author that's why i was
invited on to dr phil to discuss these
issues which if you haven't seen those
clips you should watch that too that
some of that might factor into this
movie as well maybe even more
importantly if you haven't picked up a
copy of my best-selling children's book
you should do so immediately it sold out
in 48 hours when it was released but
don't worry more copies are on the way
reserve johnny the walrus now on amazon
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know every hollywood action film
these days must it seems by law feature
at least one ass-kicking woman who can
tussle with men three times her size and
knock anyone to the ground with one
swift punch to the jaw uh most movies
now tend to feature multiple women of
this type all of different races and
sexual orientations and all united by
the fact that they they don't need no
man to bail them out fight their battles
rescue them from dragons open their
pickle jars they don't need any of that
now i have in the past confess confessed
to a certain annoyance when it comes to
this familiar trope
i admit that i i can't really take a
young attractive 110 pound actress
seriously in the role of an assassin or
gunslinger or enforcer or any other sort
of ruffian
now sure movies are fictional but but a
woman of this type
who can physically dominate strong men
is so outside of the realm of actual
human experience that every film which
features such a character automatically
becomes kind of a cartoon
if you're going to have scarlett
johansson
slapping dudes around it might as well
be minnie mouse doing
of course i say that i can't take a
young attractive woman seriously in this
role but but she still rates higher on
the believability scale than a
middle-aged woman i mean queen latifah's
50 years old out of shape female
and yet she stars as the violent
imposing rough-and-tumble protagonist in
the cbs show the equalizer it's like if
they took
liam neeson out of taken and replaced
him with your aunt betty um action
movies have always been absurd i mean i
of course we admit that featuring many
scenes where
vastly outnumbered and outgunned good
guys somehow managed to single-handedly
disarm and defeat rooms full of bad guys
but at least it used to be like bruce
lee or bruce willis doing that
but if they remade die hard today john
mcclane would be jane mclean and he'd be
played by brie larson or somebody it's a
whole new level of absurdity
these psychological ropes suspending
disbelief
can only carry so much weight
and yet
if i were not such a terrible
quote-unquote sexist and i took
hollywood at its word
and feminist at their word
and the left in general at its word
and believe that there's nothing
inherently ridiculous about a woman
physically going toe-to-toe with a man
that i'd be all the more confused by the
latest news from the us army as the
daily wire reports
on wednesday the us army revealed its
new fitness test called the army combat
fitness test which has changed
requirements so that it boasts different
scoring standards for men and women
sergeant major of the army michael
grinstein the service's top enlisted
leader declared i'm really proud we're
moving forward we're there we're doing
it
in most cases the standards will be
lowered quote following a
congressionally mandated report from
randcor
a washington dc-based think tank that
found nearly half of the services women
could not pass earlier standards for the
tests
military.com adds
the most significant changes to the six
event acft is that it no longer is meant
to prepare soldiers for combat
but instead built as a general fitness
assessment military.com explains some
differences in the expectations for men
and women for example
a female soldier between 17 and 21 years
old now has to deadlift between 120 and
210 pounds while a male soldier has to
deadlift between 140 and 340 pounds in
that same age group female soldiers have
to run two miles between uh 23 minutes
22 seconds and 15 minutes 29 seconds
while
male soldiers must perform that exercise
between 22 and 13 minutes 22 seconds
but they aren't just lowering the
standards for each exercise they're also
completely getting rid of
any exercise that women have struggled
to complete historically
so going back to the article says leg
tucks which were required by the
previous standard have been eliminated
to measure core strength the new test
requires planks instead quote test
designers were concerned that the leg
tuck doesn't strictly measure core
muscle strength but also requires that a
soldier spend a lot of energy on upper
body and grip strength previously the
plank was introduced as an alternative
event during the acft's beta phase when
it was discovered women were struggling
with the leg tugs
and why are we doing all this is the
question what's the point of frantically
changing and lowering the fitness
requirements especially at this
particular moment in history
with the possibility of war
unfortunately hanging over us
i mean we are looking at the possibility
still of a world war
and so right now is when you decide to
lower the fitness test
well here's the answer
quote steem picked up for army planners
to create a new test around the time
when combat arms jobs such as the
infantry and calvary were opened to
women in 2015. the force initially
sought to create a gender-neutral test
and attempted to juggle dueling goals of
creating a more inclusive force while
also creating a fitter force researchers
at rand found that only 52 of enlisted
active duty women were able to pass the
original design for the acft compared to
92 percent of men in their
congressionally mandated study released
wednesday only 42 of women in the
national guard and 41 percent in the
reserve could pass
41
yes this certain group of people
are widely
incapable of living up to the
traditional fitness requirements for the
military and so obviously what we must
do is lower the requirements
so that more members of that group can
be in the military
now this is logically unintelligible on
a number of levels starting with the
fact that the very people who advocate
for and impose these kinds of changes
are also likely to claim in the next
breath that men and women are the same
women are no weaker than men and in fact
to stay on the subject of the day
the entire category of woman is
essentially non-existent
how can all of these ideas coexist how
can women be equal to men
while at the same time the word woman
means nothing while at the same time
in the name of inclusion we have to
lower the standards for women because
these women who are totally equal are
also it turns out generally much weaker
than men yet exactly the same
how can you make sense of all this
together well you can't at least if
you're looking for you know coherence
grounded in anything resembling
objective reality or truth
but it starts to make sense in its own
way when you understand first that
leftists are relativists this means that
the truth itself changes depending on
the situation
at some level these people are
able to contradict themselves in the
same sentence and yet believe both
contradictory claims simultaneously
cognitive dissonance is their stock and
trade it comes with relativism
the truth is relative to whatever their
needs feelings desires and goals are at
any given moment
also we must understand
that the leftists running our
institutions to include the military
are not only engaged in a war on truth
but also in a war on this country
they want to destroy it they want to
tear it down
they want to reduce it to rubble
so that they can rebuild something new
and hideous from the wreckage something
conceived in their own image
you would not actively work to make your
military weaker
unless you wanted to destroy your
country
so
if it seems like this is deliberate
that's because it is and that's why
today maybe not the army itself but the
people in charge of deciding these kinds
of policies
are canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
today on the ben shapiro show katanji
brown jackson says she's a neutral
arbiter of the law but also refuses to
define the word woman that's today on
the bench bureau shall give a listen